[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to lab Roots the life
of her mind an interview series devoted
to learning how women think about their
research their field and their future
let's get started today we are in
conversation with Tommy akinbade founder
of the black women in science Network
and a PhD student in neurochemistry at
the University of Cambridge oh my
goodness
um Tommy's scientific research centers
on the inflammatory mechanisms of
Aggregates and Alzheimer's disease
interested in science since childhood
Tommy founded the black women in science
Network as a response to the lack of
Frank conversations probably any
conversations about being a black woman
a black woman in science and the
supportive Community such conversations
generate
the image of what it is to be a
scientist is changing and must continue
to do so if the Sciences are to achieve
a comprehensive understanding of nature
so getting to chat a bit with Tommy is
one way to to help us do that
um thank you for joining us today uh
sorry thank you for joining us uh today
and uh giving us a bit of a glimpse into
the life of your mind no thank you for
having me it's honestly a pleasure to be
here and I'm very much looking forward
to the conversation that we're about to
have a good thank you thank you so my
first question is about
um us getting to know a bit about you
um how did you find your way to
neuroscience and then specifically uh
neurochemistry with the specialization
in Alzheimer's research
yeah so Neuroscience my journey to
neurosciences it's not necessarily a
weird one but unfortunately I don't have
the kind of thing where I knew from the
age of four and I wanted to be into
Neuroscience because I didn't know what
Neuroscience was at the age of four so
what I can say is that I studied
um
biology at gcses which in the UK I guess
is that bit that you go to before you go
to kind of your senior years of
secondary education and
uh there was this one page in the book
about the brain and it was it was one
page out of maybe 200 pages in the in
the module about um the brain and I was
just like fascinated by it and I kind of
was going through school in terms of
yeah like I can do it which I was very
blessed to be able to do it but then I
found this page and I was like oh this
is what it means when people have a
passion about something this is what it
means to be excited to learn something
and I kept going back to that page
whenever I had advised I'd be on that
page for ages just thinking about things
and I wanted to know more and it was one
of the first times that I'd generally
wanted to know more I'm curious by
Nature so I'd always had curiosity and
various different topics even topics I
wasn't good at but this one felt a bit
different
so not really know anything about it I
did my exams put that aside went on to
do my um a levels which is the two years
before you go to university or college
and I kind of forgot about that page
because it never came up again and then
it came to the time where I had to apply
for universities and I again I could see
people being really passionate about
things and wanting to do things and I
was still quite lucky in terms of I
could do quite a few things like I could
have gone into Finance or and various
different subjects but then for some
reason I remember that page and I was
like I want to study that page I wonder
if it's possible to study that page and
I looked into it a little bit more and I
realized that Neuroscience was a thing
and I could do that one page for an
entire degree and possibly for the rest
of my life I was like okay sign me up so
um there aren't many Neuroscience
straight degrees there are a lot of
courses that do biology than you
specialize in neurosites at the end of
the year but I knew I didn't want to do
biology I wanted to do Neuroscience so
that's how I found out about
Neuroscience so I did the degree
um I always say that I hated my degree
but I love the subject in terms of I
hated exams I did not like exams I did
not like having to do calls work but I
could have sat in those lectures for
years like I could happily assign
lectures over and over again I found it
so interesting
um and I realized I decided when I
started doing the research I love the
research and I wanted to go into further
study and to do a PhD the path to PhD
wasn't seamless and which I'm sure we
might talk about
um later on but um I came across the lab
that I'm doing my PhD in now and they I
basically I have two supervisors I have
a supervisor that is a professor in an
immunology and then I have someone who
is a specialist in um Imaging protein
Imogen and in biophysical chemistry and
protein Imaging so their roles combined
have formed a project that is looking at
the neochemistry of Aggregates and
Alzheimer's disease and I'm looking
specifically at the kind of epigenetic
modifications that happen over the
course of Alzheimer's disease so that's
how I've found myself in Neuroscience
just a lot of it started from a page in
a biology handbook and then it's
summoned to doing a PhD at the
University of Cambridge I am just as
confused as everyone else how this
happened
you mentioned elsewhere that you um
did not go straight from your
undergraduate career to your graduate
career you
um how how did that come about what have
been the benefits do you think of taking
a little bit of a break and and working
either in your area or adjacent to your
area before entering the PHD program
well I I have to confess and be honest
it wasn't intentional to take a break I
wanted that straightforward path of
finish PhD and then get onto the Working
World before I'm 25 did not happen that
way due to due to many things I think
dude I I will say hands up a lack of
knowledge into what it takes to apply to
a PhD and how to apply to one and where
to look and what a PhD really is
um and also just the market of
um the nature of the world like I needed
to do a funded PhD that was no way I
could fund it myself so um the no I
wouldn't say there's a lack of
opportunities for funding but there's
more people at the time when I was
applying there were more people than
there were funded places so um there was
a combination of that and um just to
give people context
um I graduated and then I was unemployed
for about six seven months looking for a
job just adjacent to science
um or just something similar to science
um and eventually I found a job in a a
Medical Laboratory
um associated with the NHS our national
healthcare service and I was working in
a virology center and I started that job
in February 2020.
and yeah a month into that job it became
a perfect Testing Lab yeah everyone
knows every time you say 20 20
everyone's like oh God we know what
happened
so yeah so
um by March 2020 we were we were a
full-blown cover testing lab and I was
there for
um the rest of the year so a complete
accident but that's where I ended up and
then after about
um nine months working there I ended up
working at a um another Lab at the UK
dementia Research Institute one of their
centers in London and I worked there for
a while and then moved on to my PhD
eventually and I have to say that I
didn't the like the journey to PhD I did
not do it alone so many people advocated
and helped for me and were like
screaming and shout out to institutions
like how could she not have a PhD why
wouldn't you let her in
um on social media and various things
like that so I thank all of them for the
fact that I'm able to be doing a PhD
right now but having said all of that
even though it wasn't intentional
there have there are definitely benefits
I'm a little bit older I'm a little bit
wiser I've seen research and it only
affirmed to me that I definitely did
want to do a PhD having to head fight
for it even though I don't think anyone
should have to fight for education and
having to have fought for it I do value
it so much more than I would have if I
just walked straight into it
um I also think like I've been able to
gain various experience I know a bit
more what I like and what I don't like
um and yeah I'm just I just have that a
bit more knowledge so some things are
just quicker for me to learn than they
are for other people who may have never
had the experiences that I've had so
I've had a lot of a lot of warm-up time
um before starting the PHD which is
which is fine and also also to say those
who do go straight into PhD nothing
wrong with that
um both sides there are there are perks
to both sides
and so it sounds like apart from what
you just said about about people around
you directly or or from afar saying hey
you need to be you need to have your PhD
it sounds like prior to that at least in
your undergraduate career there wasn't
much in the way of kind of support and
you know sort of
I don't know helping you as an
undergraduate think about what could be
available to you like I oftentimes will
you know ask people what they're
interested in et cetera Etc and it's
amazing and and I mean I was like this
myself I think we're all like this but
yeah I'm reminded oh people don't know
unless you share with them right what
possible career paths there are so
um but but was there not much in the way
of I guess mentoring in your undergrad
program so I would say so it's difficult
for me to give a there wasn't this
conclusively I can only kind of give my
experience so I can tell you for a fact
on paper they definitely did have
lectures that said there are the options
to a PhD that option to do this when
they were given those lectures I think
the key thing for me was that I was
already Bamboozled by the fact that I
was at University that I couldn't really
think beyond that so and it and when
they were presenting these opportunities
I there was the voice of my brain was
like this is what worked for them it may
not work for people who look like you
because I didn't see anyone who looks
like me giving these messages so I was
like okay great like you are given this
advice to people
um but is it for me because a lot of a
lot of the
um the access to education had not been
tainted to me or hadn't thought about me
being included in that narrative so a
lot of opportunities they were saying
but you required for instance placements
or experience I was not in a position to
do unpaid placements which is what they
usually were at the time that I was
studying so I was like okay you're not
talking to me when you're saying these
opportunities are available so I think
there was an element of that so as much
as there were there was the kind of
General mentoring it wasn't until I got
very specific guided mentoring and like
to people who I still very proudly call
my mentors today it wasn't until they
were advocating for me and telling me
that you like you told me you can do
this it wasn't until I was like oh okay
maybe I can do this and I would say I
went on a research placement year during
my degree which wasn't encouraged by my
lecturers but it was encouraged to other
people
um
I went on that placement year and it
wasn't that placement year that it
rebuilt up my confidence
um in the fact that I could be a
research and I could be a scientist and
I had to be in it to see it and again
those people were mentals to me for that
year and showed me that there was space
in science for me and they didn't
sugarcoat it they didn't say it would be
easy I got saved the reality of what it
was like and I said okay I'm making an
informed decision and the fact that I
want to stay in science and you and use
my skills in this field of research
is one one as you're speaking I'm
thinking partly of um
so I hope this will make sense and not
take up too much time but but um so on
the one hand we we understand the
scientific Enterprise as you know
involving
um you know expanding expanding
expanding our empirical knowledge right
um and since empirical knowledge is
effectively
um you know contingent and limited by
each you know individual
um it would
it would seem to make sense that you
would want to have you know as many
um varied experiences in the mix right
as possible
um and yet obviously historically
whether we're talking about the U.S or
the UK right in the Sciences that's not
the case right scientists tend to look a
very specific way and the the the
default uh inference whether it's it's
unreasonable or not is that oh I I don't
I I don't look like that so I don't get
to do it
um is is that something like what your
talking about having experienced
yourself that it's not that people
weren't you know
good Educators and all the rest of it
but there wasn't this idea hey this
person might not realize because we look
different that you know us looking
different shouldn't be relevant to
whether or not they can do this work
yeah I think I think that's a huge part
of it like I don't I can't say there was
an active
it's it's you that can't do this it's
you that can't do this I think it was a
case of there wasn't the encouragement
that like no we do want people like you
to be doing this and we in fact we need
people who have your background and have
a different background to from the
lectures point of view looking around at
ascertain from different backgrounds for
myself to be doing this and yeah I think
it was a case that no one needs to be
pulled aside to be like you can do this
like you can do that and I just I didn't
get that
um do you know sort of I don't really
blame the lecturers anymore I think at a
time I was quite angry and
um
just floating that down
um because my peers were just flying and
just like seemed to have such an easy
experience
um but I think now that we're speaking a
lot of people are speaking more and
saying no that like it's it's not a case
of you need to just
quietly accept people you do need to
quite vocally accept people and just say
like look I know there are differences
in this room and that we've all come
from different backgrounds but that
makes you a better scientist if anything
so am I right to think that it was when
you went into the lab you left school
you went to work that you began to
for for lack of a better word you begin
to see where where you fit in and why
that was the case can you say a little
bit more about what how that what
happened yes sure so it was a sandwich
year so I did my first and second year
of University and then
um there was you had to find if you
found the placement you could go ahead
and go and go and do a placement so you
have to seek out yourself so it was and
because it wasn't mandatory it was a
little bit hard ass because we had to
you literally had to reach out to
professors and say hey can I spend a
year with you
um so I did that I reached out to person
and for the fact that someone said yes I
was already a bit like oh okay you're
saying yes to me this is weird like why
would you want me to come and be in your
lab and I went and I was treated as a
scientist and I think that's the first
time I felt like I was a scientist and
it was a case I think it was a case for
me where I was I didn't have any peers
so I was almost throughout and I sat in
an office with other people with PhD
students whilst I was literally I had no
degrees at this point and I was just my
thoughts were taken and considered and
considered important and it was like
yeah you have views we want to hear it
and I think that's when it was a case of
like oh my brain is valuable and I can
add something to to scientific research
and I I think that was the first time I
think being it might have taken me being
removed from my peers or being removed
from a situation where I was
um kind of always the student and just
the student that's being taught by the
lecturer I was now the student that is
informed in the lecture like we should
do this research we should do that so I
think being given some individualism and
some almost respect to my to my mind
um it was a case that I was like okay I
can do this science thing and that that
definitely transformed my thinking and
it was it was the first time that I felt
like I could say I was a scientist
now as you're so so
how how how close are you to finishing
so um to finish in my PhD yeah and so I
am a year and almost six months in so I
technically have two years left it's
very daunting to say that and it does
not feel like it so I'm probably I'm
approaching halfway so I'm definitely
still early on but I'm approaching
halfway oh but it's I mean given what's
been going on you know the past few
years like you said earlier you know
starting in March 2020 that's you know
that that's a huge accomplishment
um how so
um when you began your program had
people come back into the physical lab
or did you have to begin online so my do
my program officially started October
2021 yes that's right so officially
started October 2021
um and
it was
sorry I said that wrong what's happening
yes October 2021 yes my program
officially started October 2021 so the
physical world was open but we were
cautious so we still had face masks
um also my lab is based on a hospital so
there's the added kind of thing of that
right so
um I it was still face smart and it was
work if essential so you still had a lot
of people working predominantly at home
um and especially based on the college
system that the University of Cambridge
has there was this sense of a lot of
people live in the places that they're
studying so there was kind of this
blurred line of we need to be super
cautious but we also kind of need to get
back to life happening so it was
definitely still rich I would say it was
open but restricted
um and then we were teased out of it
very slowly I think towards the middle
of my first year and I think that's when
we started kind of walking around
without face masks in certain areas and
kind of easing back into it so there was
that return so I I believe I got the
kind of like the remnants of the heavy
lockdowns and the uh I would I don't
want to say peak of the pandemic because
it doesn't work like that
um but the we were getting used to being
a pandemic so I got to that stage where
we were transitioning almost out of the
shock waves of it but we were more
becoming like this might be a normal for
a lot longer
um so I did have the remnants of that
and had the side effects from that but I
definitely can't say I was one of those
years that was heavily affected like I
know some people's phds majority of it
was in lockdown
now okay so if you started in 2021 you
had already got several years uh of
um the black women in science uh Network
going
um so so there's there's you you you
have already done so much as I like
where to begin podcast events right but
probably best if if you tell the story
um how long did you want to start an
organization what are the key features
of the organization
um yes you're based in the UK but
um are there are you planning on let's
say chapters or if we're spreading out
into to other countries
yeah so yeah so
direct me on this story because I can go
on many tangents because it has been a
wild Journey
um but yes the black women in science
Network I started in 2018 and that is
when I was on that placement year doing
research and the first time I felt like
a scientist
um because that was the first time I
started thinking about whether I could
have a job in science or what a life in
science would look like and when I
looked I again didn't see myself so I
would I kind of was looking around and
trying to ask certain questions that
were related to being black and a woman
in science and there was no one to ask
that question to in my immediate
vicinity
um as much as the people that I had were
very clued up and they knew what was
going on in the world they didn't have
the same background that I did and they
could relate to on various different
things it was very diverse environment
however it wasn't there was no other
black woman in in that I could speak to
so in reaching out to people I spoke to
other black women in science who my
peers usually and they felt the exact
same way so I was a bit I was a bit
concerned I was like why are we all
struggling in silence we're all always
the only ones in our departments so I
kind of didn't wait to answer your
question to start it I just realized I
said I need to meet these people they
need to meet me we like we have
questions that aren't being answered and
we're just everywhere and Twitter was
almost too big of a space like social
media platforms were too big of a space
to find each other so I created a space
outside of all of those platforms and in
which we could exist and share with each
other so I started it pretty much
immediately as soon as I felt that I had
the need for it because I knew I wasn't
the only one struggling
and then it's kind of grown since there
so that was in 2018 and it's kind of
grown since there and
um we yes I'm based in the UK so it is
more so based as a UK organization
however we do have worldwide reach at
the moment because as people in science
no we move around a lot so and we're not
really held down too much by a physical
location so and most of the things we do
um do have a virtual capacity to it and
because majority of our existence has
been in a pandemic
um we have most of our stuff is online
so we're an online platform and we do
exist worldwide and I would love for us
to touch that touch soil touch American
soil touch worldwide soil because as
much as there are differences of course
in physical location and the experiences
that black women would have around the
world there is this unity and community
that we can form and despite those
physical differences and it would be
great to take it worldwide just we just
need someone to help us get there but
we'd we'd be willing to go worldwide and
I think that's the key thing that we're
trying to do is to almost to kind of
descend science a little bit and
um because the more we put down these
physical barriers which are necessary
sometimes but the more we enforce them
when they aren't necessary the more we
kind of limit ourselves from reaching
out to as many people as possible and I
want to make sure that every black woman
in the world feels that they can do
science if they want to
so is it the case that the
when you say
that you're looking for basically an
opening to to to spread is it a matter
of of funding or sort of um not I don't
I don't know if I should say venues in
other countries like or or maybe let's
say you know connecting with um a
working scientist in another country who
wants to to host events in that country
or in that City how like what what does
that look like that when you think about
it's spreading yeah so what yes I think
what it looks like is
um I think what it looks like is we have
multiple different aims so um I should
say our the kind of strap line our
slogan is
um a space a platformer movement
um so a space being we we create private
spaces and safe spaces for black women
to come and share their understanding
and to just be themselves and just
offload and feel recharged a platform in
which we believe that we amplify the
voices so we don't actually create
narratives we just amplify the
narratives of black women
um for them in because we have the
privilege have been in space that they
may never be able to answer so we just
amplify their voices and we also want to
be a platform that raises up the
individual black women in science and a
movement in terms of we want to change
the narrative and just not kind of just
exist on the sidelines we want to come
back into the wider world and just say
look this needs to change and like
create change and progress so
yes anyone I think it is a case that
anyone who wants to fund that because we
are a non-profit organization we do
every all of our events are free we
don't charge for anything again to
remove that barrier to access it is a
case of funding it's a case of funding I
guess to get us over there and to hold
us and host us to create spaces that
black women deserve and it is support as
well so that could be whether it's space
venues it's people advocating for us and
sharing that we exist on multiple
different platforms and sending people
our way and kind of just giving us that
credibility in different spaces in which
people have not heard of us before so I
think it is I think it is that it's a
multitude of things and there are so
many people who can help us and we do we
are very lucky and we've been very lucky
and we only exist now because we have so
many generous people for instance the
entire network has been run by
volunteers and they generally give up
their time and they can their time and
expertise to various different things so
there's so many different ways um in
which that in expansion worldwide could
happen but yeah those are just a few the
ways that that could that could work
and um I noticed so for example the when
I was looking at the website and
specifically at the podcast I was struck
by
so I was struck by the the fact that the
the
the podcast episodes
um weren't aimed exclusively at uh black
women scientists working in the science
Sciences but also at just you know any
black woman and
um concerns that that have to do with
being a black woman today regardless of
of where you are
um and so I'm wondering if
I'm not quite sure how to pose the
question but I think it has something to
do with
um how your network the the scope of the
network is goes beyond you know
scientific research and working in
science yes yes absolutely because I
think it is a case that when we do get
black women who are in science together
so many different things come up he's
like yes we all have an interest in
science we are also black and women so
we have multiple different we have
multiple different things that we
experience in life based on the
different groups that we exist to and we
exist within so and it is a case as well
that we have the reason of this first
season of the black women's science
Network podcast was black women's health
is because there were so many
conversations and I realized that
because we work in sciences and a lot of
us our Sciences are related to
healthcare we have this ability we have
we have the nuance and the the privilege
of having the knowledge of Science and
how it works and how Healthcare is
impacted by sciences and also having the
lived experience of being the black
women and it's a conversation that that
has been happening because we brought in
so many people who are having the
conversations but it just wasn't
happening on a big enough platform for
me and it wasn't in a space that it was
collated and it was easy to access for
everyone so it the it the podcast kind
of speaks to that in the terms of it's a
a space where so many different so many
women from so many different disciplines
are able to have a conversation about
Healthcare and for me it was about
opening up the floor to people who
aren't traditionally scientists because
again
right now it is a privilege to be a
scientist the pathway to be a senior
scientist is very it's laced in having
had so much privilege and so many things
um handed to you that means a lot of
people who do have the knowledge and the
ability to be scientists are not
scientists so whilst I believe that the
accreditation does deserve credit there
are so many people that that have
and insight and the ability to think in
such a critical way but it just will not
be afforded the title based on their
background what they look like in their
previous life experiences so we wanted
to kind of remove that
need for someone to be a professor or
anyone senior and this is scientific
field to have a voice in that
conversation and open that floor and
really value the lived experience and
the personal research and the individual
research that people have done into
different versions of healthcare so that
was kind of how that was birthed and it
was again
um just looking I think as a network we
looked at ourselves and said we are so
lucky to be able to have studies I say
lucky lucky is probably not the right
word and we we have somehow managed to
be able to stay in it with the science
game and there's
a way that we're able to approach
questions that are really impacting our
community and we should feed that
knowledge back into our community and
because they're usually looked at from a
lens a white lens
um or a westernized work lens they're
usually looks at in that way and those
aren't the lenses that we're able to see
through at the same time so that was
that was the main reason for that
podcast and why
um it was done the way it was done for
the first season
but one of the things that I I find so
exciting about just the existence of the
organization and the network and its
work is
um
this idea that that there's so much that
let's say somebody like me doesn't see
because of my particular embodiment and
even if I don't have the same lived
experience
if if I don't know about it or I'm not
curious enough to ask about it right
then the the lived experience that's not
mine kind of disappears and just
selfishly
that's bad for for for me because I then
no less I'm more ignorant than I would
be if I were to know about this another
person's you know experience and so was
thinking about you know you talked about
the the network being birthed and I was
thinking about in the US you know
stories that have only slowly and more
increasingly come to light about for
example
um uh black women
um dying during the the pregnancy
process or in childbirth you know why is
that and why weren't we paying attention
to it Etc et cetera et cetera so
um when you talk about
um having a space and a space that
allows also for the amplification of of
voices which then presumably generates
um at least an awareness
uh on the part of people who aren't
um black women right can also lead
towards some sort of of change and I'm
wondering all this said
um what you think about progress so I I
was thinking about this movie
um hidden Figures it's about this in the
um I think at Langley in the early 1960s
there were um black uh women
mathematicians and this movie
um was a was about how these women
um
became
real voices in I know it's a complicated
story but real voices in um uh the work
of some really important projects
and I'm at an age where I think okay so
it's the early 1960s here we are in 2023
and stuff that I thought was we were
done with when I was a kid in the 1980s
comes up again and I'm thinking gosh I'm
a dum-dum I thought oh we're done with
this and I'm so wrong so all this to say
like where how
do you sort of Envision a future in
which
this conversation is really just an an
historical artifact
I mean I would love that to be the
future I would love I would love that if
that's the change that we've had but I
think
um as you've said
history isn't even repeating itself I
think it's repackaged itself it's just
repackaged itself I think it is
um a lot of the struggles have just been
repackaged I'm sure people who are
around in the um 60s 80s would say that
progress has been made which is which is
fair I think that overtly things like
the overt layer of it has changed and it
probably has reduced in some way
um but then there's some ways that the
racial aggression has been repackaged
for instance microaggressions
um and I think that I hope that we
continue to progress that's what I'm
saying I hope that we don't remain we
don't get stagnant that's that would be
something that's terrible but I do hope
there's a progress I would love it if in
the future that my future kids they're
like racism what's that
um but the the the I'm not sure we can
undo centuries of aggression and
Misfortune in that short period of time
I really do hope progress is that and I
think progress for me looks like this
conversation happened less and people
thinking oh it's not that bad anymore
um I do I do hope that in 10 years
people listen to this conversation and
be like that is not a thing about
experience that would be my dream and
that that is progress
um but I think if any of us are looking
for the removal of any sort of um
challenges that you face as a black
person in our lifetimes we probably
don't understand the extent of the
experience of black people currently
my goodness I think
um that's a well it's partly heartening
partly
um not so heartening
um to to think that um we're not going
to in maybe in our lifetimes
um get past where we are
um but yeah I I when you
among a number of things that struck me
um about what you just said was this
idea that
um we we don't just
um think that we've gotten past a
certain point because we're not seeing
um
experience other people's experiences
and events but but that it's actually
the case right and I think about that in
in terms of what I
um thought when I was younger and even
as a as a as a as an adult namely oh I'm
not seeing certain things so we must be
okay and it didn't occur to me
to think to ask whoa just because I
think that's okay or just because I
think we must be okay because I'm not
seeing X Y and Z you know does that mean
it really is or I'm just not you know
seeing it
um you know who do I need to ask about
their experiences
um which I think brings us back again to
this to the to the project
um of of science right as this expanding
body of knowledge that yes adheres to
certain uh methodologies and principles
and so forth But ultimately relies on
the the robust diversity of voices and
experiences to to to proceed so for
example you mentioned earlier that it
was that when you were treated as a
scientist you thought of yourself as a
scientist for the first time and
you were encouraged to share your
thinking
which reveals a lot of the the
creativity at the heart of really good
scientific research
um do you how do you
um
how do where does your scientific
creativity come from does that question
make sense yes no yes it does
um I think
there's an element for me of Natural
Curiosity I've always been that I was
always that kid who asked why I was
wanting to know why is this happening
why is this happening
um and then I'd be answered like no but
why like I'd always wanted to know the
the reason of wise I think that's part
of my that's part of my curiosity I
think a second part of my curiosity has
stemmed from the fact that I realized
that we don't all see the world in the
same way so I'm just even that question
of is your blue my blue is do we all see
the same thing and like what is
definitive and how do we answer that
question I think it's my creativity
comes from the fact that I've been
empowered by multiple people now and to
believe that I have a unique sense of
thinking so that allows me to dive deep
into it and to just have the confidence
in that what I'm thinking could be true
and it it is valuable and I I would say
that's where my creativity stems from
because I believe I think everyone has
the capacity to be it they just need to
be given the room to be and I've just
been blessed and to have been given the
room and platform to to be creative
um I think it's it's similar to maybe
artists will hate that I say this but I
would say it's similar to Art in terms
of
yes you can have people who aren't the
best kind of traditional dancers but are
they who decides who's a good dancer and
then there's no wrong way to to have
um creative thinking with insights and I
do think that we have to be able to kind
of visually and we have to imagine you
have to you have to let your mind Roam
if you want to do research science and
who is to say what's bad and good yes
there are memorable boundaries that we
should obey and stick to
um but in terms of
thinking and trying to dive deeper into
something and trying to find something
new that doesn't exist you do have to be
creative in that element and yeah it
goes back to what I said at the
beginning it is a case of
being afforded this space and the the
being encouraged that you you do have
something valuable to add to the space
oh that's lovely thank you thank you
thank you so much for sharing your time
and your sharing your story
um and I'm very excited about the black
women in science Network expanding
um until it's around the globe
um and um I wish you the best of success
and hope to be able to to support you in
that effort
no that's amazing thank you so much for
having me it's honestly been a huge
question speaking to you oh thank you so
much I appreciate it and I will look
forward I hope to following up with you
again in the future